en el vídeo pasado sacamos el
determinante de esta matriz y obtuvimos
que era exactamente igual a 7 y bueno
para sacar este determinante usamos la
fórmula que desarrollamos en el vídeo
pasado en la que tomábamos esta fila y
multiplicamos cada una de las entradas
de la fila por el determinante de la sub
matriz que nos quedaba de eliminar la
fila y la columna de la entrada por la
que estábamos multiplicando cambiando de
signo o sea más menos más menos que de
hecho sería muy buena escribirlo por
aquí este determinante es exactamente
igual a 11 por el determinante de la sub
matriz de n menos 1 por n menos 1 que en
este caso es 3 por 3 porque esto es una
matriz de 4x4 bueno del determinante que
nos queda de eliminar la fila que
contiene el 1 y la columna que contiene
el 1 o sea de la sub matriz 0 2 0 1 2 3
0 2 0 1 2 3 y 3 0 0
y bueno luego cambiábamos de signo como
aquí tenemos un mes nos toque aún menos
la siguiente entrada que son dos
tachamos toda la columna tachamos esta
columna y esta fila y nos queda el
determinante de la sub matriz 1 2 0 0 2
3 200 si aquí nos tocan 120 023 200
y después pues vamos con la siguiente
entrada que es un 3 pero ahora cambiamos
de signo tenemos un + menos
la siguiente entrada que es 33 por el
determinante
de lo que nos queda de quitar esta
columna y esta fila que son un bonche de
términos por aquí que seguramente tú ya
sabes exactamente cuáles son y luego
volvemos a cambiar de signo como tenemos
más por acá nos toca un menos la última
entrada que son 4 4 por el determinante
de la sub matriz que nos queda de
eliminar esta columna y está aquí la que
es 1 0 2 0 1 2 2 3 0
sabes que de hecho lo voy a escribir
entonces es 1 0 2
1 2 y 2 3 0
esta es una forma perfectamente válida
de sacar el determinante de una matriz
de 4x4 aquí realmente lo único que
necesitamos es volver a aplicar esta
fórmula en cada uno de estos
determinantes de 3 por 3 y sacar las
cuentas pero bueno el chiste de este
vídeo es enseñarte que así como fuimos
tomando estos números a lo largo de la
primera fila
podemos usar la última fila o de hecho
cualquier fila o cualquier columna ok
entonces en este vídeo vamos a hacer un
ejemplo de cómo se puede sacar el
determinante usando en lugar de la
primera fila alguna otra fila o alguna
otra columna y la razón por la que poder
hacer esto es útil es porque entonces
podemos ver cuál es la fila o la columna
que tiene más ceros y entonces vamos a
tener que sacar muchos menos
determinantes de 3 por 3 o sea por
ejemplo esta fila tiene dos ceros
entonces en realidad solo vamos a tener
que sacar dos determinantes de tres por
tres aunque entonces saquemos el
determinante con esa fila
pero bueno algo que sí es muy importante
cuando queremos usar otras filas que no
sea la primera fila es que tenemos que
acordarnos de este patrón de que vamos
cambiando de signos aquí tenemos muy
fácil que era más menos más menos aunque
hay pero lo mismo se extiende para el
resto de la matriz o que dice aquí está
aún más aquí tiene que haber un menos y
si aquí hay un menos ya que hay un menos
pues aquí tiene que ver un mes y así y
en realidad lo que nos va a quedar es un
tablero de ajedrez que hay entonces
saber la primera fila el el patrón de
los signos para una matriz de 4x4 es
nada y luego cambiamos a menos y luego
más mínimo pero como también nos tenemos
que alternar si vamos a sacar el
determinante a lo largo de una columna
entonces aquí tenemos menos
- y entonces aquí nos toca nada menos
más menos más menos más menos más great
tal cual como un tablero de ajedrez
entonces si queremos saber cuál es el
signo de cualquiera de las entradas de
la matriz ósea por ejemplo esta que está
en la tercera fila y tercera columna o
sea esa es la entrada a 33 entonces nada
más nos tenemos que fijar en nuestro
tablero de ajedrez ahora para no tener
que estar yendo a ver un tablero de
ajedrez de 50 x 50 o de 100 por cien
pues lo que podemos hacer es definir una
función a la que generalmente le
llamamos signo entonces le ponemos así
signo
d
y hot en donde y es el número de la fila
en la que están y j es el número de la
columna que nos interesa bueno el chiste
es que esta función el signo de j nos lo
va a mandar a menos 1 elevado a la
potencia y más jota ok para el caso de a
33 pues lo que tenemos es menos 1 a la
33 eso es menos 1 a la 6 y como 6 es paz
nos queda un 1 o sea nos queda positivo
a ver otro ejemplo digamos que nos
interesa el signo b a 43 ok entonces el
signo del signo de 43 es menos 1 a la 4
3 pero 43 7 y 7 es impar entonces aquí
nos queda menos 1 aunque ellos se nos
queda signo negativo lo cual concuerda
con a ver a 43 está en la cuarta fila
uno dos tres cuatro y tercera columna
123 aunque nos queda este signo que es
menos o sea que si corresponde tiene que
hacerlo porque esta función fue diseñada
para que coincidiera con todos los
tableros de ajedrez de cualquier tamaño
pero bueno ya que tenemos todo esto de
los signos bien entonces vamos a sacar
el determinante usando esta última fila
que tiene dos ceros y vamos a mover este
signo a un lugar donde nos estorbe menos
entonces calculando el determinante a lo
largo de estas
la que tenemos es la primera entrada
este es un dos por el signo de cómo
estos dos está en la cuarta fila y
primera columna entonces y es igual a
cuatro y jota es igual a uno o sea que
según nuestro signo nos toca un menos
porque menos uno a las cinco es menos ok
que además coincide con tenemos aquí más
menos más menos aunque entonces tenemos
menos dos por el determinante de la
matriz que nos queda de quitar esta fila
y esta columna aunque yo sea 23 40 20 12
32 34 020
1 2 3 y entonces como aquí tenemos menos
aquí tenemos más baja aquí nuestro
tablero también nos dice que tenemos más
+3 por el determinante de lo que nos
queda de quitar esta fila y esta columna
sea 13 4 1 3 4 1 2 0
120 023
0 2 3
muy bien entonces más o menos nada menos
más menos que menos cero por algún
determinante pero como esto ya es cero
entonces sea lo que sea que nos dé del
determinante de tres por tres de quitar
esta fila y esta columna de todas formas
como lo vamos a multiplicar por cero nos
va a dar cero y lo mismo nos toca aquí
un +0 por otro determinante que también
termina aportando cero a nuestro
determinante entonces de hecho hasta los
vamos a borrar ok aquí ya los estamos
borrando
y estas cuentas para sacar este
determinante son mucho más sencillas que
todo este chorizo de cuentas más
entonces ya con esto de usar esta última
fila para sacar este determinante en
lugar de la primera fila ya
simplificamos muchísimo al determinante
pero bueno no vamos dar satisfechos
hasta que demostremos que realmente nos
queda el mismo determinante si usamos
esta fila en lugar de esta fila o sea
que hay que terminar de sacar las
cuentas pero para sacar estos
determinantes de 3 por 3 podemos volver
a aplicar lo mismo por ejemplo esta fila
de aquí se ve que tiene muchos cero así
que por lo tanto muchos determinantes se
van a eliminar entonces vamos a usar
esta fila para sacar este determinante
muy bien entonces este determinante es
igual a menos 2 por el determinante
este determinante que si lo sacamos a lo
largo de esta fila nos queda más o menos
algún determinante de una sub matriz
pero como lo estamos multiplicando por
cero nos queda simplemente cero y no nos
importe y después vamos con la siguiente
entrada que es este 2 es un 2 por su
signo que es + - más o sea está muy bien
y la multiplicamos por el determinante
de la sub matriz que nos queda de
eliminar esta columna y esta fila ósea
de la sub matriz 2 413
4 13
más
este es 0 con signo + - + menos o sea en
realidad estamos restando le 0 por algún
determinante pero como es un 0 no nos
importa porque no va a aportar nada
entonces ya terminado de calcular este
determinante está súper sencillo no o
sea en realidad este determinante de 3
por 3 si lo calculamos usando esta fila
es equivalente a calcular un
determinante de 2 por 2 muy bien vamos
con el siguiente determinante tenemos
aquí
más
es que este 3 por el determinante este
determinante okey entonces aquí tenemos
que escoger una columna o una fila donde
se vea que va a ser más sencillo el
cálculo de este determinante pero pues
aquí teníamos una fila que tenía dos
ceros
aquí pues no hay ninguna fila ni columna
con voceros pero hay una fila con un
cero y una columna con un cero debería
de calcular este determinante a lo largo
de esta columna para ver que también se
puede a lo largo de las columnas pero
vamos pasito a pasito entonces vamos a
calcular el determinante a lo largo de
esta fila que ahí empezamos tenemos aquí
uno nada menos más 0 0 por el
determinante este determinante pero como
estamos hablando de un 0 realmente no
nos importa entonces nos vamos con el
siguiente y entonces nos toca más menos
más menos menos 2
el determinante que nos queda al quitar
esta fila y esta columna o sea que nos
queda 1 y bueno aquí hay un pequeño
detalle ok y estaba poniendo aún más o
menos pero en realidad no es que yo
estuviera cambiando la matriz ok aquí
nada más estaba indicando qué signos les
tocaba a estas entradas si las usábamos
para sacarle terminante que aquí en
realidad éste no es un menos este es un
mes este también es un mes y bueno
entonces el determinante es esta columna
y esta otra columna ok 11 4 0 y a eso le
tenemos que sumar 3 por el determinante
gay porque sumamos restamos y aquí nos
toca a sumar otra vez ok entonces
tachamos esta fila y esta columna y nos
queda nada más
11 32
que hay entonces haciendo las cuentas
vamos a calcular estos determinantes
entonces dos por tres son seis menos
cuatro por 16 menos 4 esto es un 2 o sea
de aquí tenemos 12 pero luego lo tenemos
que multiplicar por este 2 aunque
entonces de 2 por 2 nos queda 4 o sea
que de todo esto nos queda un 4 y
finalmente hay que multiplicarlo por
este menos 2 aquello entonces finalmente
todo esto nos queda un 4 por menos 2 o
sea menos 8 y de este lado aquí tenemos
de este determinante 1 por 0 0 menos
cuatro por uno o sea menos 4 x menos 2
nos queda menos 2 por menos cuatro menos
por menos más y 2 por 4 8
8 y aquí tenemos 1 por 22 menos 3 por 1
o sea 2 - 3 - 1 x 3
o sea que de aquí tenemos menos uno por
tres menos tres entonces de todo este
paréntesis verde tenemos ocho menos tres
o sea un cinco que hay aquí entre
paréntesis tenemos al 5 y ese 5 está
multiplicando a este 3 o sea que de todo
esto lo que tenemos es un 3 por 5 15
todo esto todo esto es igual a un 15 y
de todo esto aquí ya sacamos que es
igual a un -8 así es que lo que tenemos
es 15 menos 8 y 15 menos 8 es igual a 7
y 7 es exactamente lo que nos había
quedado en el vídeo pasado pero las
cuentas que hicimos en el vídeo pasado
fueron muchísimo más complicadas aquí
nada más tuvimos que calcular dos
determinantes de tres por tres y uno de
ellos realmente realmente era
simplemente un determinante de dos por
dos
y además nos tardamos menos entonces la
moraleja es escoja en la fila o la
columna que tengan la mayor cantidad de
ceros y no se olvide eso sí no se olvide
de su tablero de ajedrez de signos